you know I had the mean Jimmer Thomas
some below-the-belt and it I don't know
how I feel about it he said this then
you give me your take on this you know
all these guys saying they want more
money all the stuff he says fighting you
see is not a career it's an opportunity
soak that really interesting that's a
really interesting thing to say isn't it
and I I have to say I don't entirely
disagree that's what I said I mean if
the and this is with all due respect if
my son comes to me and he's really
talented
se then he's got all and he says I fight
I want to make a career of fighting I'd
go and he said I wanted to be MMA I
would say to him are you going to be a
champion and are you gonna hold that bow
for a long time because that couldn't be
a worse career choice in a lot of here's
the prong B's I went on this whole rant
on how you should look at odds when
you're making a career decision I
understand look I was an actor we may be
correct you still are hmm you know you
didn't know I mean yeah that's yeah so
I'm gonna duck I'm gonna dice this good
couple of get your lids down pop you're
not gonna it's true but you you can only
get odds in anything so if your son
comes you and goes dad I want to be in
the UFC and go if do you want to hold
the bell he goes oh no I don't wanna be
that good then he shouldn't do it right
any I guarantee you I will get everybody
any fire he's gonna ever talk everybody
wants pitching he talked to me when I
first got to UFC they said what's the
goal the battle champion now every
single person I'm saw last Saturday
night fight every single person a
brilliant career
oh [ __ ] a career every single person
believes on that car through the next
Conor McGregor it's the only way you're
even gonna get to the day it gets you
through training it gets you through
competition to get you give you tour
every moments yeah I agree you can't
step on anybody's dreams you get in
dreams are irrational and dreams should
be irrational a lot of times you you
will feel like so many people I say what
do you want like I said what you want
what would you ask for if you knew you
couldn't be refused that's a really
important question because it forces you
to face up to act what you really want
but most of us don't say that to
ourselves because if there's no way
right it sounds irrational but most
dreams are not rational most dreams are
pretty crazy it's like a lie honestly
when you say you like good odds the
reason I get so excited when you come
off and crush after you know and when
we're on the road when you tell me you
want to be a stand-up I was very worried
oh yeah I mean I
we should and then frankly tell me you
want to be a stand-up I said this is a
disaster yeah and I tried to kind of
talk you out of her now and you do a
joke about it because what happened my
boys got really hives I go yeah oh cool
oh oh oh I said when he said I want to
be a stand-up coz he was hard for him to
admit it I went oh yeah oh okay okay
that's all I could say because I didn't
I didn't know he why I I always knew
he's funny but I this is a very
difficult gig yeah but imagine if I
listened to everybody well the hundred
me but that's not a me but it's a good
message to [ __ ] it's my say mister
for people that read comics online why
would you give any of those people
validation on anything look because if
you listen to any of that you're never
gonna do anything yeah because they
because they didn't chase any their
dreams and that's why that's where the
hate and the regret comes from in the
hate that someone who's living their
dream that's where they out they they go
Adam they lash out at buddies it's it's
hard
don't listen your friend you listen your
family sure especially your friends and
family actually I would say especially
online any person you admire any person
might never listen to comets or what
family or friends said because anyone
with a rational brain would go no you
can't do that yeah cuz that's preparing
your own parents my my own an acting
teacher used to say don't go home for
the holidays because your parents and
your siblings are gonna talk you out of
your dream and they're gonna talk you
out of your dream because they love you
and they're worried about you and I'll
and I'll tell you this
yeah her family friends or online can
talk you out of your dream then you
shouldn't be doing it yeah there's not a
person on this earth who they're talking
about doing anything I want to do they
don't exist whether it was you Rogen my
dad Jay there's not a person man yeah if
I want to do something I'm gonna do
you'll do what I say you'll do what I
say well I'm gonna dock your pay then
you're not gonna knock Shane your boss
you're not gonna die you by not my boss
do it a sang-bong and I got a flat hand
that says yes and I got a flat hand and
says even harder yes all right good news
and bags I like that hold on I've good
news and bad but rain the good news is
not take the wisdom I just dropped
yeah the bad news is
boss I'm gonna take 60/40 now nothing
boss moss buzz right but my hand is
heavy my hand is swollen on your right
on let me call the boss and see what he
says about the merge split hold on yeah
is this Brendan I know this is him hey
you want to do 80/20 listen dude he
needs now KITT no I talked about they
want to do any twenty but I'm not gonna
do though that that but I'll tell you
this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue oh good what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]